in this video i'm going to complete an
entire film well attempt to in the back
of this moving truck
[Music]
why well let me tell you
let me tell you about something called
load shedding
but before i do i wanted to let you know
that this video is sponsored and that's
how i get to do all this weird and
sometimes just questionably like why am
i doing it stuff and the sponsor of this
week's video is artless and art grid
which i'll tell you more about later but
now more about load shape
load shedding is the deliberate daily
shutdown of electric power in separate
grids around the country in order to
prevent the failure of the entire energy
supply which will result in a nationwide
blackout escom which is the south
african electricity public utility
claims that the lack of electricity was
caused by generator breakdowns as well
as a higher demand for electricity i
don't know the truth but it's really
serious and currently when making this
video we are on stage six which means
that for six hours per day in each of
the 31 grids across south africa we'll
be in complete darkness this also
drastically affects the cell towers so
you can't access the internet via mobile
as a filmmaker without access to
electricity and the internet this makes
it super challenging okay let's move on
i do have this inverter thing which um
are you serious bro okay
as you can see what i was going to say
is this thing only gives me two hours
therefore what i'm going to attempt to
do is beat load shading not like that
but by creating a studio on without
solely but rather create a studio on
wheels so that i can constantly stay
connected to the internet as well as
power but mainly the internet for at
least 24 hours
we are currently here in zone 15 and
today the bird shedding moves from here
to here to here then here and then back
there and then here again and then here
so here's the plan
i'm gonna rent a four ton truck
insert two large battery packs a strong
mobile wi-fi connection
mount two desks to the floor add a
cooler with essentials for the day
an office chair
my laptop and screen along with mouse
and keyboard a reliable hard drive a
voice over recording setup
a whiteboard
lights
[Music]
led strips for aesthetic purposes a fan
two two-way radios a lot of foam
that i don't break any
ah [ __ ] a bike helmet knee and elbow
pads a ball box to protect the jewels
first
and a bunker to protect my this and
lastly my good friend abdul he's gonna
very safely very fast and
very fast yeah safe and fast fast and
safe
either way okay fast and safe that's how
we're gonna do it
[Laughter]
see you on the other side
[Music]
okay so the challenge is to complete an
entire film in this moving truck from
writing it to editing it to grading it
to doing the sound design in all less
than 24 hours then i'm gonna play it to
you and that's if i can actually
complete it
let's go
okay abdul i'm ready let's go
okay let's go
not too bad
okay so the best way to get this done is
to use art grid for the incredible stock
footage because obviously i can't shoot
anything in here
the idea would be that i'm going to
die
okay i'm going to
write the idea
and then do a voiceover over there this
is the hardest part of any film
writing it
taking down it from all the areas there
is a connection
story story story story
okay i'm gonna use this truck the four
walls are some sort of metaphor
[Music]
i hope it done
[Music]
okay i'm abandoning standing
[Music]
i think i have an idea
okay the script is done it's
it's as good as i could do okay
[Music]
finished recording my voiceover put it
on this card now onto the next step
okay we left zone 14. cool wi-fi that's
all that matters now i'm going to import
this vo
chop it up in the edit then search for
stock footage then music and then cut
the stock footage to the music
alrighty
just for a variety of frame i am done
with the voiceover i'm now going to
search art grid
for the greatest
oh good
odd grid is amazing basically i don't
need these token points
oh good
odd grid is amazing search engine
like you can literally type in any word
inside
hello
now i can create a collection
called truck video
and i'm just going to add these to that
yeah
all my favorite stuff that i like yeah
and then i can literally just download
it my super fast wi-fi abdul can we stop
the truck
i need to pee yes
are you watching me let's get back to it
yeah i felt like
okay round two
so we entered in zone 15. now that i've
got all the footage what i'd like to do
is find music i know this is a brand
deal but i'm in all seriousness i'm
being really really real and it's
amazing to be able to say this but
artness legitimately has the best music
you can get and
time to set the tone with music
i just found such a good track
heartless
you're killing it it's an artist called
bunker buster
[Music]
i'm done with the edit it's rendering
out then i'm going to click export
[Music]
exported
it's exported
after i finish the film
that was the toughest thing i've ever
done like legitimately
the toughest
thing
i have ever done in my entire life
[Music]
i made the film
from beginning to end well done well
done
before i show you the film let me tell
you a little bit more about my friends
at artless and art grid
[Music]
potlus offers access to downloads of
over 22 000 songs and 27 000 sound
effects that are uploaded daily like the
personal plan that covers all your
social channels that's either built
annually at 119.88
to just be very specific there or it's
bold monthly at 14.99
or you get the unlimited plan which is
the one that i have because i use the
songs and commercials as well as on my
social media channels which is 199
spoiled annually there's a lot of
numbers oh art grid art grid is awesome
so use my link below and get two months
free of an annual subscription on both
platforms it's an insane deal and you
get access to both art list and art grid
okay i hope you enjoy the film just
about to press play enjoy
sometimes it feels like i'm stuck inside
four walls while the world moves quickly
around me
i'm disconnected but connected at the
same time
much like if i was stuck in the back of
a moving truck the thing is that i've
put myself here am i escaping or am i
progressing am i disconnecting from the
world out of fear or because i want to
focus on building myself
finding myself
i can't answer this question i mean i'm
just the guy quite literally flinging
around the back of a moving truck trying
to edit this video
but i can't ask you
why are you hiding forget the world
outside don't compare yourself to anyone
else or even consider it as something
that is moving faster than you are if
like me you're actually obliviously
moving faster than it
you may just not know it yet
zoom out and
you do you bruh
i don't know
it wasn't bad oh yes
like subscribe to
look i go through all of this to make
these videos and sometimes i think why
but then when one person subscribes
and turns their notifications bowl on i
go
yes
it's all worth it
okay
so give me that feeling
and thank you
i'm asking so much of you uh i love you
and i hope you know that other than that
don't forget you're awesome and
i'll see you next week
[Music]
wow